good afternoon everybody and welcome to
the referrals meeting of mid Suffolk
District Council now first of all remind
you of some domestic arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs the cold water
is also available in the bright breakout
area outside the meeting room if the
fire alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs and meet at the it's switch Town
Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you are told
it is safe to do so please switch off
all the mobile phones or turn them to
silent I would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting annual training purposes the
council members of the public and press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting when the public and press
are not lawfully excluded finally can
members and officers please ensure that
you press the microphone for speaking
and turn off when you've finished thank
you so do a few introductions my name's
Cathy Guthrie and I'm the chairman today
and coming along the table we have in
Despres our legal officer of general
walker and senior planning manager and
then we have Robert Carmichael the
committee officer and Daniel Cameron
who's planning officer today and we also
have Majesties with our internet
connection person we have I'm not sure
what to call it but it was very rude of
me to forget your name anyway
and then we have planning officers and
members of the mid Suffolk District
Council over there who some will present
the case or recalled bits and pieces of
it we have members of the committee who
will go in to debate and come up with a
resolution to the applications and
ladies and gentlemen in the audience
over there can be the Parish Council
objectors supporters applicants and the
ward member who I think is sitting over
here will go over there and for those of
you who haven't been here before we do
have the point where when each person
has presented the case if there's a
relevant question and a question only
not debate they can ask either the
officer or whoever's presenting the
information a question so without
further ado can we move on please and
but before we do I think we need to go
onto the agenda I think it would be fair
decorations right so apologies for
absence and substitutions Thank You
chair we have apologies from kalsa
Humphreys councillor Richardson and
councillor Carter and councillor Turner
thank you and to receive any
declarations of pecuniary or non
peculiar interest by members and I think
we can all put our hands up that we know
both of the applicants so I think that
would be fair to say is that a few
cancers won't know all of them you don't
know either of the two so this
the first application then will be for
canceling Marcin that we know and then
for the second application for Council
of India had enough following on from
that I've had discussions with a couple
of members about the specific situation
my understanding is Council and Norris
has said to me that he as somebody who
was ex counselor mrs. marched if I can
call that fellow board member as well as
a member of the same political group he
feels that the former cooperation as
colleagues in one Ward and nature of
friendliness is such that he ought not
to participate in this item or and I
think in any event he would be going
over there as the ward member if he was
staying but although the letter of the
law doesn't oblige him to he's decided I
think sensibly to go out the room for
the first item counselor field has also
taken my advice simply on on the
cautious and sensible basis that he was
a member of the same political group and
in his own judgment he's quite able to
make a proper decision on this matter
and that sounds absolutely sensible to
me so he is he is has declared the same
interest as all of you but he will stay
and to participate and he's not the ward
member so I think that that deals with
all those issues thank you and we come
on to declarations of lobbying so those
of us who've received emails and no yes
item one yeah and also for item two
because canceler Marchant has sent an
email round today did I have the miss
late papers them and I had these papers
that were sent to me then from the
second applicant like papers then ok
those right I read them last night
that's all
so they were late papers so not to count
that's my error on that one okay so it's
just the second one declarations of
personal site visits confirmation of the
minutes of the meeting of the 27th of
February and if I can just take them
from page one through to page nine and
unless there's any amendments can I take
them as read please
and the same for the minutes that were
on the 13th of March from the first page
through to page 8 can I also take them
as read unless there's any alterations
thank you very much I'll mark them
during the meeting
to receive any notification of petitions
in accordance with the counselors
petition scheme none receive chair and
the schedule of applications will be as
presented so if we can allow our
colleague to depart the room and we'll
move on to the first application but
before we do we have a little bit of
extra information so Jim is going to
tell us a bit more
[Applause]
[Applause]
Thank You chair yes I just wanted to
pick this up quickly with members both
items having some of the same issues
both were presented to committee
previously and because they are member
overturn of the officer recommendation
and both are now wearing and caps much
as face counselors the requirement
through the planning Charter is for them
to come to referrals that's why we're
here to look at those because of that
they've both got the recommendation from
their original committee that that
committee was minded to approve against
the officer recommendation so I just
wanted to pick up today in terms of the
decision making process for today we
have got that minded to from those
committees that they made those
decisions but in terms of decision
making today we do need to bear in mind
the special regard that we need to have
to protecting preserving buildings their
settings features of special
architectural or historic interest which
is section 66 of the planning mister
building and conservation areas act that
we have to have special regard to and in
terms of the actual decision-making the
MPP F the paragraphs 193 194 195 196
that what your paw refined we were 30 if
at any point you'd like us to clarify we
can do that but just very quickly we've
got to give great weight to an assets
conservation and then more importantly
asset that greater the way it should be
and then when we're looking at harm
we're looking at no harm less than
substantial harm substantial harm and as
you go up through that scale the weight
to be given and the argument for that
harm should be greater as we go up I
think in both places we're talking less
than substantial Hall is what a Harris
team have suggested to you if if you
agree with that we need to be
considering the public benefits than
light outweigh that or if you think
there was a different level of harm
that's what we need to understand from
you to move forward with that decision I
hopefully that helped what we need to do
is follow those requirements of the
planning a listed building act and the
MPP F so we can make that decision
that's not then at risk for members
from judicial review sorry thank you for
that so Daniel if you'd like to start
the presentation please thank you very
much thank you sure yes so the
presentation is as was shown on the 24th
of April from this was last seen so if
we move forward that's the application
so I identified large sort of two
l-shaped buildings behind other former
and council offices in needham market so
that site should hopefully be familiar
to members this is an overlay placed on
the previous plan showing listed
buildings within the area green denote
in grade one listing Orange do not in
grade two and read not in grade 2 star
it also shows t POS within the immediate
vicinity we've got a number of great two
listed buildings although obviously as
you move further down the high street
you do have a great one and off the high
street nor why we do have a great two
star listed building again is similar to
the previous map that's just over those
the conservation area for need a market
just to demonstrate to members that the
application site is firmly within the
conservation area as well we have the
aerial map which actually in this
context is less useful than the on-site
photos but if you run through the
submitted plans first I'll just explain
the works than the numbers again site
layout plan much the same as we've
already seen this is the existing
elevational plan of the building it's a
simple rendered to sell building you can
see the barge boards decorative barge
boards on the side there the
ground-floor and then raised window and
this is the proposed elevation with the
pole shooting inserted into the render
and it's a combination of scroll ivy
leaf work with Tudor roses at 3:00 to
the Roses within
at various points this is a photo of the
site in question we've got the colored
render applied to the building and then
when the protruding beam at first floor
seems to come out that's when I to my
mind from the plans that we've been
shown that's why the pirating would be
inserted and then this is the same
elevation but seen from further away
down the high street in representations
made on the item the agent brought up a
number of other instances of parting and
scroll work within Needham Market
so if we run through from the Tudor Rose
in the top left through to top right
bottom right and then bottom left
they are variously at 11 High Street 69
high street Hill House Lane and number 7
High Street in researching these with
regards to number 11 and the Tudor Rose
I can see no record of an application
being made for the application of the
the Tudor Rose in render with regard to
69 High Street and the stucco Randa was
listed within its list description and
was likely applied at the time it was
constructed it may have been repaired
since but it's largely where it was in
terms of Hill House Lane these appear to
be on modern building set within a
modern editing development so it would
have been put in so there would be no
then they aren't listed building so
there'd be no requirement for this to
building its own or planning application
to insert those and then the last one
number 7 it is listed within the list
description given by historic England
there's likely being applied sometime in
the 1980s it doesn't get any more
precise than that just circa 1980 but
there's no evidence of an application so
it may have been applied prior to
listing
in terms of the report before members if
we go back the elevation as presented we
had the lesson substantial harm
identified by the councilors heritage
team we then went through the process in
terms of the justification for that arm
and could find no public benefits to
outweigh the lessons done to harm
identified hence the recommendation of
refusal given at the previous committee
in terms of the previous committee we
have obviously the details listed for
members and officers have also provided
a list of likely conditions that members
would want to consider should they want
to approve the application contrary to
officer recommendation at the previous
meeting there was a discussion about
whether or not the color of the render
on the building would change from
details sent in by the agent I
understand that the color of the render
on the building is to remain and I says
it would just be the insertion of the
pocketing we've also been provided with
details of how that would be how that
would be done the the oppositing panel
would be constructed on site then
brought to site an element of render
would be removed and then the positing
would be applied and rendered into that
finish and further details are provided
by the agent on page 31 of the report
move things over to committee thank you
very much just a slip of the tongue now
you said would be made on site it's
gonna be made on site and then brought
to the site so does anybody have any
questions for the planning officer
councillor Hicks then councillor Mansell
thank you
thank you very much and could you just
clarify for me the view of heritage and
partings so is it that parting was not a
feature of this house originally
therefore that's why shouldn't go on or
is the reason for less than substantial
harm because it's viewed out of keeping
within the vicinity of Needham Market
what is the reasons for it is it because
it's not
appropriate to a house of that age or is
it just in the locality yeah thank you
yeah the consultation from the heritage
team is is given on page 25 and yes I
think in in their view although there is
evidence of parting with in need of
market itself the marketing all tends to
be on buildings dating from a later
period than the application building so
while it is rendered it would not have
had the fine parting work that is
proposed the building itself is quite a
simple vernacular building and I think
to some degree the heritage team would
like it to remain sort of quite a simple
unadorned building there is some there
is some detail on the frontage of the
building with the initial C going over
the initials RM I haven't got a photo of
that for you unfortunately but it is
listed within the within the list
description given on page 27 that also
contains the the date 1716 which I think
given the likely age of the building
from the list is not original that was
probably added at a later point I think
also to add to that we've got the
Heritage team report on page 43 which
amplifies it as well then cancel amount
so thank you thank you chair I'm looking
at the elevation diagrams on pages 39
and 40 and they show that the eaves I've
sort of forgot a scalloped edge but the
photograph that you showed me look like
it was a straight edge so is that gonna
is that part is that going to happen
anyway that they're going to do the
scalloped edge of the barge boards on
the eaves or it's the diagram not gonna
happen as a perfect photograph so in
terms of the listed building concerned
the works they can carry out are the
works that they described within the
application which only extends to the
budgeting
the drawings are provided for clarity
they are conditioned so that we can
ensure that the the detail is provided
but no the scalloped edges to the barge
boards if if the applicant wanted to
apply those we need to be subject to
another listed building consent before
those they couldn't introduce those
scallop barge boards with within this
application we do actually have the
architect here so we can ask that
question to the architect when they come
forwards but thank you for that to
information did anyone else want to ask
the officer a question can't to the
field just issue issue of the existing
when do I understand I think from the
report that it's been replaced
relatively recently is that correct so
it's not been there for the agent the
house for instance potentially yes there
have been a number of works relating to
to this one I think looking down the the
list of planning history associated with
this with this application there's the
insertion of new windows in in 1984 so
presumably has been there has been there
for some time and we also have the 1981
application for a new window in timber
shutters to the to the front elevation
as well that's weather as well as
various other other listed building
works that we've got dating back through
the nineties and noughties though it
doesn't it doesn't form part of this
application it is just shown for to
reflect the actual elevation that we're
that we're discussing thank you any
further questions for the officer thank
you very much indeed then we'll move on
we know from we don't have a parish
council objector or supportive we have
the applicant applicants agent which is
Martin O'Shea if you'd like to come
forward please and take a seat just up
there and you have three minutes
madam chairman if I may just briefly
I'll save mr. O'Shay using any of his
precious three minutes just to say that
I was made aware by mrs. March and this
week that mr. o'shay's very recently
become a member of neither market Town
Council but I've advised that that's not
a problem because he's not he's here in
a professional capacity to represent the
applicant he wasn't involved in the
parish council deciding some beg their
part in the town council deciding what
their response would be so his
membership of it now is purely
coincidental and and not relevant thank
you so mr. O'Shay if you'd like to make
your presentation that will be fine
thank you well the client came to me
with a request that targeting be
designed and incorporated in the
elevation of our house it's in a problem
prominent physician within Needham
Market it's one of the first some houses
The Gables of the houses that you see
when you come into the town from the
Ipswich and the positing itself is not
necessarily a thing which is done just
once of the original construction of a
building positing is a thing which is
lived over a good few hundred years and
people are still applying it to
buildings for various reasons maybe for
information for decoration for to try
and recover a bit of history which has
been lost over time and I believe the
depositing that mrs. Martin wants to put
on the front of her house on the side of
her house would would enhance the high
street of Needham market and would make
Needham market even more genuine in many
ways than it is at the moment because
lots of the things have been lost over
the years shop fronts have been put in
people have done things without
permission
buildings have lost their historic
interest and their historic originality
and I believe that the positing as
proposed would in fact return some of
needham to a more interesting and in
and attractive ciao
thank you very much does anyone have any
questions I'm sure you would like to ask
your question thank you q yes can I ask
you about the diagram on the papers that
we've got that show a scalloped edge to
the barge boards on the eaves whereas
the photograph showed a plain edge odd
board is described as shown on the
drawing those photographs of old
photographs
this is currently scribed by whiteboard
right the way up to the cable and that
that drawing is an accurate
representation of what the barge wood is
actually like so I don't know how old
the pictures were that yes I have a
photo of what is currently life which I
chose and your season just a minute no
that's all right um camera can we just
ask did that have planning permission
then so could we have at the time that
was changed because mr. Cameron is
telling me that the photographs were
taken recently I don't know how recently
is recent within the last year
mr. elbisi for it okay well we will move
on from us at the moment but you've
asked the question we haven't quite got
the answer to that will ponder in that
Ardi date I think possibly does anyone
else have another question at all no
right if you'd like to return to your
seat then thank you very much indeed
a mr. Osho do you want to just give the
photograph to the planning officer and
he will just offer it up to our
colleagues it's not normal that we do
that but I think under the circumstances
because of the confusion we should just
have the opportunity to look at it
so moving on councillor phillips isn't
here and of course counsel and Norris
was quite rightly decided to leave the
room so we're actually now open to
debate if somebody'd like to pick off
that would be fine at the moment we
haven't yeah we haven't sort of got
details of when that was done or whether
it needed planning question would it if
needed planning submission so it would
have made it listed building consent
excuse me mrs. Marcin could you just
come forward again for us I'm sorry to
get you bobbing up and down there I've
been asked by the or I've been advised
by the planning officer that in fact
planning from listed building consent
would have been required do you know if
you have applied for listed building
consent to have those barge boards in
the vernacular they are did building
consent wasn't applied for it was done
at the time of the rendering who tell us
roughly when last year
right that sounds a dog question thank
you very much indeed
so I'm being advised by the legal that
it's a different issue and not relevant
to this we can sort that out under
another section of mid suffix so
councillor Matheson yeah just to say
having the photograph we've just seen I
can confirm that is very recent because
of the scaffolding on the Institute
building which yeah so does anybody want
to sort of enter the debate as to what
we should be looking at - yes indeed
council mayor I look at the the posting
and I see a fairly plain building in
that has its own beauty parsing and now
the additional woodwork seemed out of
place so yeah we're trying to turn the
building into something that it wasn't a
vision yes counselor wall boys
I think I'd just like to follow on from
that it's not just the actual building
itself but the context of the building
it's in the context of several great -
listed houses which is which are quite
simple and straightforward and the
introduction of an element of decoration
like that is it would be actually quite
alien I think and I support what the
heritage officers say is about it thank
you thank you very much thank you yes I
mean I think that the addition of
targeting on the end of that dwelling is
probably you know open to personal
interview some people will think it's
very attractive others may not find it
so attractive I think it's you know it's
in the eye of the beholder it's it's a
piece of artwork but I mean I can't
disagree with the
two officers comment is that it does
completely change that the face of that
gable end and it's very prominent as
you're approaching need a market along
the along the high street and and what
does it say you know we are we are told
that if there is any harm less than
substantial harm to a listed building it
needs to be outweighed by public benefit
and I can't I mean it may be a benefit
to the occupier of the house they may
like the look of it but I can't see that
it's got any public benefit so at the
moment I am inclined to go along with
the officer because there clearly is
some harm because you're making a very
prominent change to a side of a building
that everybody will see as they walk
down the high street and it is it's not
as it was and therefore it is harmine
I'm not I'm not one to wrap her old
buildings in cotton wool and say we
never changed them normally I'm not that
it's fast about history but sorry what
is the public benefit in this
application are the moment I can see
none so at the moment I am I am going
towards going along with the officer
recommendation thank you for that well
being a member on the previous committee
we were as you know minded to approve
but I did personally ask for further
information as to how this was going to
be applied and we've now been given that
information in this document on page 31
and it strikes me as though this is
going to be almost like a picture put on
the side of the house and I do tend to
agree with what you've just said there
and hindsight is a wonderful thing so I
am sort of more in keeping with the
Heritage officer's views at the moment
because it's subjective as to whether it
is public benefit but I will carry on
and listen but I thought I'd put that in
because I was on the previous committee
so councilor muller please thank you I
must do it I do agree with the comments
and my colleagues I personally cannot
see any public
- this at all and I think it looks it
should remain as if he's basically in my
personal opinion cancel Madison
yet my my approach to listed buildings
and heritage offices over a lot of years
now has always been that the you know
that to respect their professional views
I know very well I'm not an expert in
listed buildings and so I I will I will
look for the the need to do something to
the building to to maintain it in in a
continued use to stop it crumbling a way
or to give it you know 21st 21st century
purpose but this this doesn't this
doesn't seem to fit into that at all so
I take my usual view really that the the
professions know what they're talking
about thank you thank you very much it's
it's interesting isn't because really
public benefit I think on this is
subjective and it's very hard to say
some people are going to think it's
absolutely improving the building others
are going to think that actually you
know and they want to see a bit of
decoration there others will think like
the Heritage team that actually is a
historic building that never would have
had that in the beginning and therefore
adding it at this late stage is actually
causing some harm although less than
substantial harm so and I grew actually
agree with councilor Matheson's comments
that you know this this doesn't change
the use of the building the building
will still continue to be at home with
or without this so I'm afraid I'm going
to also come down on the side of the
officers recommendation and I'm afraid
I'm happy to propose refusal as laid out
in the papers yes Kevin thank you and
thank you very much chair I'm employed
colleagues and I think that that's what
one of my colleagues has said not to
wrap him well not to wrap historic
buildings up in cotton world in a way if
it was a farm
or modern addition it might actually you
know have have had some kind of purpose
you know to end public benefit but
trying to put something back onto it
that may or may not have been there
doesn't seem to fit with the opinion of
the heritage of offices and I'm also
minded to agree with the the officers
and I'm happy to to second more young
colleagues proposal thank you for that
counselor does anyone else wish to speak
counselor field
thank you I think I tend to go with a
view we shouldn't employ heritage
officers and then ignore their advice
you know it is a professional advice I
do look at the list of changes that have
been made to these this building they're
all pretty minor they're obviously all
between improve its qualities as a
dwelling place and we do want to keep it
in in use quite clearly and obviously
committees of various types have taken
that view over the years so I'm a little
concerned that in rejecting this we're
rejecting what is a pretty minor change
but I'm one that I think is councillor
Hicks mentions may or may not be
considered as appropriate other visitors
to the town anita market in reviewing
the building from the public realm so i
certainly have some difficulty with this
decision but i think overall my view is
we should stick to the recommendations
of our heritage offices all right thank
you for that does anyone else wish to
speak all because I have a proposal in a
second oh can we go to the vote so in
that case I have a proposer and a second
there as per the recommendation
page 29 to refuse it and so all those in
favor of the refusal please vote and
those against an abstention thank you so
thank you for your full debate on that
thank you very much indeed
so we move on to the next case oh yes
can we get back
we're just waiting for the counselor to
return so thank you very much
right thank you very much if we can
start again please page 47 and John is
going to present the case to us today
thank you thank you so this is both
householder planning application and
listed building consent for an extension
to the lobby so the application site is
Eastern Mendham it's in a very rural
location and it's part of a wider
farmstead it is a grade 2 listed
building and just opposite the site we
have a public footpath where effectively
there are a few constraints it is
identified as potentially contaminated
land given the farm uses within that
location but that's not a specific
designation within the local plan or any
of your policies it's just a constraint
to highlight there might be some issues
there that we'd have to look into
essentially that wouldn't apply to this
application though in terms of an
extension to the property itself and
again this is also within a influence
area for the triple-s I so we are aware
of that constraint but ultimately in
terms of the nature of this application
being an extension we don't have any
concerns in that respect either so the
application in terms of an aerial view
is a fairly well enclosed mature garden
there surrounds the site it says it's
not really spreaded leave seen outside
of the site and if I carry on forward
just to explain where we are lysed a
very war location and it Mendham is to
the left on your screen so you can see
the distance from the nearest more
significant population so back to the
block plan
look at your screen so ultimately we
have the the public highway running
along the corner here public footpath
was opposite but the site itself is for
this extension which is at the rear in
terms of looking at the highway to the
property and is enclosed by the L shape
of the existing building so existing
elevation so this is what's there at the
moment
now the photos are quite helpful in
looking what we're looking at a rendered
listed building we have on the one side
a modern extension just there but the
proposal site is in respect of this
fairly unaltered elevation currently
when with this is obviously was it a
committee and members were minded to
approve subject to looking at some
alterations to the proposal so this is
the proposal that members saw at that
last committee and this is the
application then since that committee
officers looked to renegotiate the
scheme and some of those details are in
your late papers as well but essentially
if he's now changed to this design we
have the glazing within the apex removed
we have the posts either side of the
doorway also taken away from the scheme
to simplify the proposal and we have
some clarification over the access to it
there was concerns about suitable access
and we have a handrail that's been added
to this detail in plan form the proposal
is essentially unchanged from the last
committee we are looking at a lobby area
and internal WC
and they're looking at the photographs
so we have the the modern extension or
more recent extension on on the left
hand side and we have the area where the
proposed Lobby in extension is proposed
to be here so just circling around and
looking straight on to the area in
question just get an idea of the area
and of course this is part of a larger
farmstead site as well so it's very
active in that regard
hopefully those photos give you a
general idea the site and its contacts
thank you so in terms of this proposal I
think it's fair to say that there are no
real planning issues other than the
essential one which is regarding the
listed building and the degree of harm
or no harm that we were looking at in
respect to this application it has been
taken from our heritage officers and
your officers recommendation that this
does cause harm and on that basis it's
called lessen substantial harm in this
instance could we feel this is
detrimental the character of the
building is an only fairly undeveloped
part of the building and so for the
recommendation the most one of refuse or
as stated in your papers however members
have been minded to seek approval
subject to some changes to the design
and that's come forward to you today
those changes have taken taken place and
essentially do reduce the appraised this
sort of higher status appearance of the
building has perhaps been toned down a
little bit but still doesn't negate what
we deem to be harm in the context of
less than substantial harm and so for we
are maintaining the office of refusal in
that respect members obviously need to
assess whether they still maintain it
does or doesn't cause harm and if they
do consider it does cause less than
substantial harm they may wish to then
look at what possible public benefits
would result and that's my presentation
thank you thank you for that just to
obviously flag up to members that
they're aware as well as page 62 is the
original design and so that's why in
late papers we've got the new design and
[Music]
certainly a lot of it has been altered
and as both planning officers have
mentioned we've got to look at public
benefit which we can go into in more
detail in the debate but I just wanted
to point out that these new late papers
are the design that the officer just
heard up on the screen so we need to
have that in mind
so does anybody have any questions for
the planning officer counselor Mansell
um yeah I was trying to look at the plan
I think the best one to look at is the
one we've got on page 60 which has got
the unnamed Road which I believe is a
public right-of-way on my on the OS
markets green spots which i think is of
road uses public path or something is
what what in you know will the view of
the porch be visible from that public
right-of-way I will say no I will look
at the case officer and just double
check but no essentially the only views
available of the extension will be
private views of the occupier or any
guests answer Mansell
oh sorry counselor Madison yeah I was
gonna gonna ask the officers to they
could put slide
12 up again I see that that's also in
the light paper
I'm just actually slightly struggling to
to understand the steps so what we
saying is that I thought it was a level
access when we looked at it before or
steps up but their steps down I see so
their steps down now with a handrail and
I see in that line you know I see that
that that line above the steps is just
indicating I don't know I think I think
I'm any further questions no and in that
case um we don't have the parish council
objector a supporter but we have mr.
Steven adding them if you'd like to come
forward we have got late papers
he presented to the Planning Officers
some time ago and we all have had a copy
of those late papers and so if you'd
like to put your case on tell us a
little more about it please feel free to
start thank you
Thank You chair and thank you all of you
I was going to read I wrote a letter up
with an update on on the position but
that the letters in the late papers so I
won't bore you with that but I'd be
delighted to answer any questions that
you may have
I just like to clarify we know we've
sort of guessed it but just clarify the
levels and the steps because councillor
Matheson did sort of yeah sure so the
the levels aren't changing the the
finished floor level in the house is
remaining the same and the and the level
of the concrete apron outside the garage
is remaining the same but because of the
extension we're having to move the steps
from where they are because that son of
the footprint of the extension to
obviously the steps that need to be
replaced so that the floor levels will
remain the same the difference in height
will remain the same but the steps will
have to be recreated further back from
the existing house and we added the
handrail because that was a concern of
the committee you know it was a
suggestion which we were happy to employ
thank you very much chair I've got two
questions if I may firstly the lean-to
which we've seen on sites of 14 and 15
could you tell me when that was added
the porch area yes the ugly linked yeah
that was that was some early 80s and by
a member of my family but three previous
owners ago and secondly understand from
the papers that the that entrance the
rear entrance of the house is used by
visitors and today could you give me an
idea of how many people
it and use that access other other than
family the existing porch is is just
just goes into mine and my wife's you
know office at the rear of the house and
the what was originally the kitchen you
know in historically and the area which
we now use as a kitchen family dining
area is is the opposite end of the house
which is why we have now got this
problem that we literally do have to
walk through five rooms to get to the
ducky say from the door which is
predominantly used so you know ninety
percent of foot traffic goes into our
you know kitchen
you know dining family area and which is
the difficult that we have if I'm a
chair that just how many visitors do do
you have as well well I mean probably
I mean business-wise probably you know
for a week yeah I think that's something
we debated the last time was that you
know you have lorry drivers coming along
people on site selling things and they
if they needed lavatory then they have
to traipse through the house I think is
that correct I'm not trying to put words
into math but that's what we did the
last time was it not yes that is correct
we don't have a toilet outside although
we obviously could do but we could build
up the toilet in the in the farm
buildings but it it's this really the
awkwardness of because that's our family
area when people come in for a you know
you offer them a cup of coffee they sit
down and have a chat in an informal
environment if they need to use the
facilities they've either got to go
upstairs through our master bedroom to
the ensuite you know bathroom or
literally walk through five rooms into
the six room which is just then if
they're a stranger do you stand guard
over the over the WC door and and you
know give the impression that you can
certainly might you know rob you or or
do um ask them to go outside again and
in through the other door and then
escort limit it's just it's obviously
slightly absurd set up the way we've got
it and it's particularly for my wife as
a as a female I feel them
you know it's very hot yeah I think
you've answered the question rather than
debating it for too long I think we've
got the gist of it yeah sorry and does
anyone else have any other questions
counts for field yes just looking at the
proposed porch
I see you've reduced the glazing area
quite substantially but do you feel it's
now in keeping with the rest of the
property I notice most of it appears to
have quite small openings and what I
thought heritage offices were a bit
sensitive to the amount of glass you've
been put into your listed buildings
yeah well that we very much like the
original and design which you've got
details of and you know regrettably um
scaled it back as you know because we'd
considered the feedback that we've had
and and then I guess that is subjective
but you know in our opinion we really
like the initial design we like this one
slightly less but they're still very
happy with it and you know I hope that
you are thank you any further questions
no thank you very much indeed if you'd
like to return to your seat so when you
sit down into the debate
thank you very much who wants to start
us off with this I don't normally start
from the chair so I won't cancel thank
you well I have to play to see anyone
else willing to put their hand up but
and as you say you don't like to start
the debate from from the chair I must
admit I find this quite difficult
because as I said in the previous
application I'm not I'm not I'm not
normally overprotective about historic
buildings and I'm not a historian I know
very little about history of buildings
but my limited knowledge tells me that a
lot of old buildings of this sort of era
have quite an ornate frontage and the
back is sort of deliberately plain it
was like you know I want to show off to
the best of my advantage what the front
of my house looks like in the back is
sort of a bit cheaper and a bit plainer
and the back of this house although it
is
it's a perfectly attractive back of the
house and the front is clearly the
dominant side of the property but I I
just feel that this porch is a little
bit too ornate for the back of the
property and although it can't or so I'm
told by the planning officer I'm not
convinced that you won't actually see
the ridge height from the road or the
public path or whatever it is it's not
going to be seen by random members of
the public walking past it's only going
to be seen by people actually visiting
the farm of which there seemed to be
quite a few so are they members of the
public or not I'm not sure but people
walking past on the footpath might or
might not just glimpse the ridge height
of the porch and although it's reduced
its glazing and got rid of the pillars
it's still much more fantasy than the
rest of the bucket of property but the
rest of the back of the property has
already been compromised with the
lean-to extension in the 80s so you know
again similarly to the last one what is
the public benefit in this it's
somebody's private dwelling and they
want a bit of space for their toilet and
the lobby area is it a public benefit
just because there happened to have
visitors to the house I'm not convinced
so I really am struggling as to know
which way to go on this but I have
opened up the debate I think it's too
ornate for the back of the property but
I'm not convinced it's gonna actually
cause any member of the public any
bother because they're not gonna be able
to see it so how important is it that it
is slightly more ornate than the rest of
the back of the property if you ask the
heritage of people they'll probably say
we should need to do it because it's
less a substantial harm and again I'm
struggling to see the public benefit but
anyway I've owned up I've said well I
think and I really don't know where I'm
going on this yet
that's very helpful I've got two hands
up here so
got cancer mayor and then counselor
field if I may please
referring to public benefit I think this
building was built as a farmhouse in the
16th century adding that extension means
it can be a farmhouse in the 21st
century you know what do I want people
walking through my house to get to an
office you know when they're delivering
whatever forms get delivered so I think
there is a public benefit I would
question the word all night I don't see
anything in it that is all night we can
argue about the glazing and I think the
reduction in the glazing makes it far
less intrusive and yeah I don't see that
reflected in the report the words
dominant due to its size well I don't
see them I don't think it is dominant I
think it is the public a similar
argument to before we employ heritage
offices for good reason they're experts
in this field and I feel that this is a
dominant extension that should not be
allowed on a building of this nature I
have to say I personally say it is
substantial it has a lot of glazing
which is out of keeping with a building
of this in this age and it is quite
dominant it certainly has a public
benefit but we have to ye the public
benefit against the damage to the
building we're told that this is less
than substantial I believe there are
some catties and graduations within less
than substantial certainly is a less
than substantial harm it's outweighed by
the public benefit of having a toilet
which is available to de visite us I
don't personally feel that it's
sufficient benefit to out by the damage
this is doing if it was significantly
more
substantial less intrusive then maybe
there will be an argument opposed Thank
You councillor Gould thank you I find
myself in agreement with Koechlin mayor
it sees you reading this it the there's
an objection not let's say to the idea
of the thing itself but to its scale if
I have that right so there's not a
matter of necessarily a principle of
having the thing bit-bit simply it's its
size and the impact it has as it is
presented on the back of the house but
but in terms of the the benefit to be
derived from having this in what is a
working farm house I'd be inclined to
want to see this proposal go forward I
mean there's a piece of design I don't
know the amount of the glazing I have
mixed views on that I mean probably
isolated from the house the original
design I think is more appealing but
that might just define me as a
Philistine I don't know a bit the idea
of it I would support the application on
the basis I said thank you thank you
thank you chair personally I do agree
alike my colleagues here on my left
I personally if I lived in this property
I wouldn't want people traipsing through
my family area there are a few people
that go this I think there is some
public benefit and I do believe that the
revised drawing is more in keeping with
the actual building itself so I inclined
to support the application thank you
anyone else wishing to speak councillor
Madison yeah I I um I was on planning B
when we looked at this before a night I
wasn't party to thee to the my
to approve actually it is it is slightly
less again I look to the offices
professional opinions if they're saying
there is there is harm then you've got
to look for the for the benefit and the
very thing you know public benefit I
think this is the actual term and that
is is rather tenuous actually so I think
I'll stay where I am with with agreeing
with offices on most of these things
thank you I'm sorry you've already had
to go so I'll have a go though shadow
yeah I think public benefit is one of
the things that we do have to explore
and I don't think it's just about going
to a lavatory I also think it's about
the living standards of the property and
my mother-in-law does have a listed
building and it's an absolute nightmare
to try and get double glazing or
anything that's an improvement to the
property and when you're open this door
at the back the wing must how lean and
how loud so I look not only for the
current usage of it but for the future
usage of generations and generations to
come
and it's very difficult to try and
improve a listed buildings green
capacity which I'm sure some of you are
all very keen on as on I and so I see a
double public benefit here is not now
for the family that are using it but for
those people that will be using it in
the future plus of course the visitors
as has been explained so I'm sort of
more in supportive of it I do think it
looks a lot better looking at the - I've
got the - propped up here from a quieter
point of view as I say and and I do
appreciate the one single door is a very
traditional Suffolk type view but really
if you look at it in its location which
is why I wanted to know the head view
you really got to have a neck like a
giraffe to look round
corner to see anything from all the
other angles except the private angles
so you know I'm more supportive of it
than perhaps some of you are so
counselor Manson you want to come back
again if you would think yeah if that's
all right yeah I just thought I was I
was listening to what other people were
saying and and I think I'm inclined to
agree with counselor field about the
size of the windows because the back of
that property does have quite small
window openings and despite the fact
that this one has reduced its amount of
glazing it still is is not particularly
in character with this small windows at
the back of the property and and as as
counts the field also pointed out we
have heritage officers who are far more
knowledgeable than the knives certainly
am about historic buildings and their
legacy so I must admit having listened
to other people's comments and I take on
board what you've said yourself chair
about to be then on you know the fact
that winds gonna whistle through and
it's going to be very cold in that
kitchen and yes 21st century living
probably does require you to have a
toilet that's accessible but but perhaps
there are other ways of doing it which
are not as big or as glazed as what we
are presented with here you know that
have other means of finding a toilet in
the near the back door being looked at
or not so I think I am happy to propose
that we go along with the officer
recommendation and I will move that as a
motion
thank you that counsel Reba Thank You
chair I wasn't on the previous committee
so I'm not wasn't party to those
discussions I know I don't have a
problem with an extension per se I I am
slightly concerned about the size and
the design of it because I think it does
kind of put a sort of front door
approach on the back of a building
but I'm not I'm still up you know
sitting on the fence as it were in terms
of which way to go I think as I say I
have no problem with their actual
extension per se and it's just
potentially you know the design and
whether it should be have more the back
of the house feel than the front of the
house feel thank you well we are sort of
nearing everybody's had a say counselor
field justice hours were fair two-second
a casual man social proposal thank you
very much for that so does anyone else
wish to speak who hasn't spoken no yes
counselor wall boys thank you
I think I attempted to I I side with the
Heritage officer's comments I think the
rear of the house at present in
particular that section there's got a
dramatic simplicity about it there's a
rhythm of positive and negative shapes
I think they the proposed extension
would I'm gonna make a word if I think
disarming eyes that it would it put all
those things out of kilter there is it's
not detailed very much on the the floor
plan but there is a modern extension a
lean-to extension which is used as an
office so there is a second access to
the rear of the building of the league
there's no on the pictures it looks as
though there's always another doorway
[Applause]
- so what I'm highlighting at the moment
is where the proposal would be the
chimney to the door there this is the
more recently extension historically I
believe they are doors just there to
access that extension and if I then just
jump up to the floor plan so that door
to the new Lobby was on the right hand
side look to that photograph they seize
an undefined area but that's the modern
extension that sits there now I don't
know
there's nothing detailed in terms of
this plan of what goes on in that area
itself it's not it doesn't need to be
surveyed for the purpose of this
application because the application is
in regard to this element over here yeah
so I think perhaps just continuing my
comments I think I think there are
alternatives to the development of the
porch well we can't suggest alternatives
or not to look at what's before as
counseling have you finished with it
with your comments
yes helpful thank you very much
councillor Norris thank you madam chair
having listened to the debate I'm
actually coming around to opposing the
officers recommendation I think the
removal of the glazing and the posts in
the additional papers we've submitted
does reduce the dominance of their
extension I take the part of the
guarding the windows of comparison at
the rear that already exists are much
smaller than the glazing in the actual
porch area itself but at the end of the
day I think these are minor points if as
opposed to buildings need to be useable
need to be habitable to endure and I
think a lot of builders if you look at a
lot of listed buildings across the East
of England and you look at the structure
of them it is apparent that the fabric
that building has been changed many
times over the years I have no problem
with the what is proposed and I will be
opposing the recommendation for repairs
on second thank you very much right well
on that we have a proposer in a seconder
to accept the offices recommendations
which are timely pages over 50 tools it
and which is to refuse the application
so all those in favor is refusal and if
you would like to vote no please is it
for for refusal yeah and those against
four six six is it six oh yes I can see
sorry counselor bulletin council it's so
that's six so I think the officers would
need some reasoning and I've written
myself down here is the visitors the
public improvement is visitors
availability two years sorry we got to
put a proposal and oh well sorry
so we've lost that we've lost the motion
sorry yeah so I know need a proposal
I think so yeah madam chairman obviously
the whoever if if another member is
going to propose approval it's up to
them if they are not the proposer and
second it will need to have in their
mind those two things and mr. Peyton
Gees just said
yeah I'd like to propose let's get this
right I'm proposing that we reject the
officers recommendation and we do whilst
I accept that maybe lesser substantial
harm I think the public benefit
outweighs that because it allows a
sixteenth century farmhouse to remain in
operation in the 21st century
how many listed buildings can actually
say they're doing the same job that they
were doing in the sixteenth century
probably long winded okay can I just
interject in the debate of what we're
doing is that not only is it improved as
you've said in the 21st century that's
for that can we do we need to define it
that the heating is improved the
facilities for visiting public because
it's public benefit that we've also got
to identify doing the more information
you can put behind what the benefits you
think are that outweigh the harm helps
to explain that reason and so if there
are things members would like to add to
that that you're happy to carry forward
in your proposal then we should do so my
understanding is working farm is that if
you don't have facilities to cope with
people coming dressed in you know dirty
boots and the like you are going to move
that facility to another building so
because they've got the extension
because they've got what I think firmers
farmers often referred to as the dirty
toilet that they they can operate still
as a farmhouse and as a working farm
without this extension my would hazard
to guess that that working office would
move to another build
and it would cease to be that working
working area and just being part of the
debate and can I just add that's public
benefit but also for the future of the
building that will carry on when this
family have moved on can we add that to
it
councillor moolah you might like to add
something yes thank you care I totally
concur what councillor and mayor says
and that and I think moving forward it
will be a benefit to future generations
using that that farmhouse etc I toad
agree there is the public benefit if
you've got if you're in a farm
environment you're going to get people
coming in directly clothing do you want
that walking through your house so I
think the public you know they've got a
toilet handy like cash the mayor points
out so I I do support his son
thank you for that so do you want to
read that out so that you can make sure
that we've got everything of course so
we are looking to recommend approval on
the basis that the proposal would cause
less than substantial harm and that
there would be public benefits that
outweigh that harm by virtue of the 16th
century farmhouse being that operate in
modern standards offers facilities to
support the farm working and the future
viability of the form sorry the farm
would be supported as a result of the
proposal does that cover yep sir
conditions in this case suggested the
most yes so obviously we've got the
planning and the listed building so we
need to do both we do so normally unless
we start with the planning it tends to
be a little bit more straightforward
conditions wise we would have the
standard time limit which is not quite
the one that's in front of you that's
the listed building one but essentially
it gives the applicant three years to to
do so so I assume that's remember to
happy with
stand at the time limit then we would do
approve plans which essentially does
what it says on the tin they would need
to comply with the approved plans the
other one suggested their condition 3
agreement of materials that would we
would usually put that on both the
planning and the Lister building just
just for completeness in addition a
couple of things come to my mind if I
can make suggestions about things
members might want to think about the
sort of the details of the proposed
hammer we haven't got a lot of details
up to members if you're happy with that
or would you go condition the handrail
that is shown on the elevation plan but
not overt above that that's up for
members if they would like that the
other thing would be implementation of
the handrail and finally we've got the
side elevation detail with the posts
removed I would suggest we might want
just that little bit more detail on how
that is finished but at that that's up
to selves I haven't written it down so
if you want to confirm or discuss them
so pencil mayor how do you think you
want to get us to word that does define
I can go back no but all right I think
they're all right so it was all right
with the three years they approved plans
and the materials yes a great so the
other systems would you want
manufacturers details of the handrail or
some more details of the hammer now it's
a big week for conditioned or do you
family tradition it would normally do
details to be agreed yep so hammering
out details to be agreed and then my
suggestion is that we have a condition
that requires the handler to be
implemented it was something that was
particularly requested previously and if
we don't have a condition that
specifically requires it you don't have
to have it to complete the development
it's one of those fibrils of planning so
we suggest given it was members wish
last time to have it that we have a
condition that ensures that does that
make sense okay and then finally it was
the elevation
plan where the timber posts had been
removed
the roof projection that's there just to
confirm that detail on the bat
projection so on page four of members
lake papers it's obviously just got the
posts removed and there's the roof
detail that to me I think we just ought
to seek some clarity on but you know
this subsea service if you're happy with
that as a recommendation okay so if I
just quickly wouldn't run through those
again then if it that's okay we're
looking at a standard time limit confirm
the approved plans that will seek
details of the materials will confirm
that handrail is to be agreed will
ensure the handrail is implemented and
will seek the clarity all the details of
the side elevation I feel free to add
small but they counselors did raise
concerns over the size of the windows is
there anything we can put in there to
ask them to read I think yeah I mean
we've suggested probably under the
listed building option possibly some
more details in terms of what we often
the seat for listed buildings is the
section details to see the windows to
make sure that the the sculpture of it
would be appropriate for this the
building we can't change the size of the
window but we could make sure the style
of it matches the listed building but
that's specific to a listed building
sent rather than planning permission
like I thought we're sticking to
planning permission for those conditions
so we were clear on the proposal and the
conditions for that and then we'll move
forward if that's okay
[Music]
on that basis all those in favor of the
proposal now before us please vote yeah
and those against right right so that's
the chairs casting vote
vice privately manager
you
you know just say a few words very well
madam chairman I think I'm very
conscious that we didn't resolve to go
into closed session it was a little bit
of regular I hope it was a fair and
practical thing that we did in you
asking for my advice I will just say for
the sake of accountability and
transparency the Chairman wanted to be
assured and reminded of the general
principles of law relating to the
exercise of a Chairman's casting vote
and the advice I've given is that she
has always complete discretion ie in big
entirely proper for her to vote what
would appear to be the same way as her
earlier though but she has discretion to
vote the other way if she feels that his
expedient to do so I'm sure councillor
Guthrie waters reflects on that thank
you very much for that well on that
reflection I will be voting with the
motion of approving the application on
the building is it called building the
planning building application and so I
will approve that so it is a motion that
is six-five
and so we now move on to the listed
building consent which we have - just a
brief debate and please what you need to
tell them I thank you I don't feel as
necessary run through the presentation
one more time I can obviously put slides
up as requested so I'm happy that you've
got all the information as it's a
there's no difference in the information
provided for both applications thank you
so if anybody wishes to speak regarding
listed building permission does anyone
wish to speak at all no so we do need to
have approval for listed building
permissions so I would need something
from
please can the officers just help what
people are looking for because they
might be a bit nervous about what we're
looking for so in terms of planning
illicit building with said we could
approve the planning consent the issues
of listed building consent relate to the
works the building predominantly I think
we're still talking about the harm issue
and the consideration of harm to that in
terms of both the works predominantly to
a degree also the impact of the building
or the extension proposed but that's
essentially what we're looking at the
same applies in terms of the planning
permission if there are conditions or
particular things you want clarified we
can add that and we can talk that
through as part of any recommendation
you might like to make so does anybody
wish to speak on it or is anybody
prepared to propose the listed building
permission council Amala thank you very
much no do we need to put any conditions
on that so again we need to just confirm
what we consider about harm and impact
as before if you want to say that you're
happy with the same considerations that
we've put forward before then that's
fine we can do that and then we would
move on to consideration conditions
which again on page 48 and so we've got
standard time limit approved plans and
materials as we said before for the
listed building consent other
suggestions that things we would
possibly normally put on list Oberto
consents is to request a sample panel of
brickwork so we can identify the brick
the bond water and the jointing that's
something we would commonly do if
members were minded to details of the
roof materials specifically a section
through the eaves and the verge of the
extension again so we can make sure the
detail if that would reflect the
historic building word which you don't
perhaps get the detail in the elevations
and detailed elevation and sections of
the proposed windows and door again we
would normally ask for that almost
listed building application
and rain water goods being to match the
existing and the details of the roof
projectors we previously suggested to be
free to add a doctoral men to those as
you Thank You chair I'm happy to go with
the Planning Officers recommendations on
that thank you so do I have a seconder
somewhere of gold yes I second on the
basis described a planning officer thank
you thank you that does anyone else wish
to speak on it at all no so all those in
favor please vote five and against and
it will go back down to the Chairman's
casting vote which having had the legal
advice I will vote with that motion to
pass the application thank you very much
to everyone and I would like to thank
the heritage officer who sat there very
quietly listening to it all and thank
you for the input that you did put into
both applications thank you very much
indeed we now close the meeting thank
you